si je vous dit emma watson secte gourou
ça vous parle aujourd'hui on va étudier
le cas d'une secte chilienne du nom de
colonia dignidad dont l'histoire a été
adapté dans un film poignant avec emma
watson alors comment 300 personnes se
sont retrouvées piégées dans cet enfer
et quels ont été les mécanismes
diabolique mise en place par ce vicieux
gourou d'ailleurs quelle est la
situation aujourd'hui en 2022 pour
répondre à ces questions je vous emmène
au chili avec victoria charlton qui
marraine ce neuvième épisode
pauvre paris deux sets 7-6 et froid dans
le dos c'était un lieu où il s'est passé
des choses terribles
vous allez voir en veut tout vous
expliquer bienvenue dans cabinet curieux
[Musique]
et
vous emmène avec moi au milieu des
années 50 où un certain paul schaefer
vient de passer plusieurs années en tant
que brancardier espèce il crée alors une
église mais surtout une maison des
jeunes dans le but d'y accueillir les
orphelins de guerre les enfants dont
personne ne s'occupe et c'est cette
partie de l'histoire qui nous intéresse
aujourd'hui faut savoir que la justice
commencent à s'inquiéter de ce lieu
puisqu'elle reçoit plusieurs plaintes
pour maltraitance et actes sexuels sur
mineurs à l'encontre de ce gourou dont
paul schaeffer une parfaite tant il
s'exile au chili avec pas moins de 300
personnes de 300 membres et hermann
schmidt un ex pilote de l'armée de l'air
avec lequel ils sont véritablement la
secte en
1961 social bénéf actes au rallye et
location al din al qui signifie société
de bienfaisance et d'éducation dans la
dignité mais quand tu penses bien
bienfaisance éducation et dignité ne
sont pas du tout trois thèmes que
j'aurais employé pour décrire ce qui se
passait dans cette secte et fabien bien
concrètement qu'est ce qui se passait
entre les murs de cette vieille ferme
isolée de 13 mille hectares au sud de
santiago en réalité des choses terribles
paul schaefer est en fait un prédateur
qui s'enfermer avec plusieurs centaines
d'enfants dans le simple but d'en abuser
il ne s'arrête pas là il transforme la
secte en centre de loisirs pour les
enfants chiliens afin d'en abuser de
centaines d'os il commence par séparer
les hommes des femmes il sépare ensuite
l'état des enfants la devise est très
simple diviser pour mieux manipuler le
quotidien des victimes est ponctuée de
prises de drogues de sévices tac
d'esclavagisme et même de travaux forcés
allant jusqu'à douze heures d'affilée
comment le gourou fait pour manipuler
ces pauvres personnes eh bien tous les
moyens sont bons délire religieux
menaces de mort privation de sommeil il
ira même très régulièrement jusqu'à la
torture la torture est particulièrement
violente d'ailleurs le film avec emma
watson ne relate pas l'entièreté la
violence des faits certains détenus qui
s'en sont sortis racontent leur supplice
notamment la torture à l'aide de
décharges électriques sur de nombreuses
parties de leur corps dont certaines que
je ne pourrais pas citer ici
pire encore d'autres victimes relate des
faits de relation sexuelle forcée avec
des animaux notamment des chiens
l'horreur est à son paroxysme le
machiavélisme de la secte va très loin
pour ne pas éveiller les soupçons la
secte vient en aide aux villageois d'à
côté en installant un hôpital un
aéroports et d'autres infrastructures
du coup certains villageois d'à côté
peuvent bénéficier de soins médicaux
gratuits
ils sont alors encouragés à mettre leurs
enfants dans la colonie et d'autres
enfants sont même kidnappé on a trouvé
le témoignage terrifiant d'un rescapé de
la secte ou alors qu'en guise victoria
nous raconte son récit
et dès sa première nuit il est abusée
sexuellement par paul chef affaibli par
les actes de tortures et sévices sexuels
à répétition il décide de s'enfuir en
1962 il y parvient il retrouve refuge
dans une famille chilienne mais là
écoutez ça c'est fou on le retrouve et
on le ramène de force à cologna il tente
de s'échapper à nouveau il y parvient on
le retrouve encore une fois on le ramène
à cologna c'est incroyable et là il peut
directement les conséquences de son
geste puisque pendant plusieurs années
il ne peut parler à personne et il est
celui qui mange moins que les autres et
il reçoit des coups c'est vraiment une
situation
horrible il est très persévérant
puisqu'il progresse à nouveau une autre
évasion et traverse la rivière à la nage
pour atteindre l'ambassade de
l'allemagne et le il pense être enfin
sorti d'affaires mais non en dénonçant
les persécutions dont il a été victime
et il est condamné pour diffamation à
l'encontre de la cologne mais
heureusement volt gagne fini par
s'enfuir et s'installer en argentine
après tout cette cavale le voilà enfin
en liberté c'est qu'il est extrêmement
difficile de s'en échapper le lieu est
sous alarme cloisonné bourré de fils
barbelés de caméras de surveillance et
de micros dissimulés quiconque tenterait
de s'échapper serait arrêtée et exécutée
sur le champ 1973 marque un tournant
encore plus terrifiant dans l'histoire
de colonia dignidad puisque c'est
l'année à laquelle le général pinochet
prend le pouvoir au chili suite à un
coup d'état militaire la colonie est
aussi mise à disposition de la dina la
police secrète de pinochet et le lieu
devient laboratoire à ciel ouvert avec
l'opération condor sans rentrer dans les
détails l'opération condor est une
campagne d'arrestations et des
assassinats des opposants politiques
ces derniers sont justement emmené à
cologna où ils feront l'objet de
tortures d'expérimentation médical et de
crimes pour la petite parenthèse en 2005
un agent de la dina a avoué l'existence
d'un lien entre la colonie et le
laboratoire de guerre bactériologique de
l'armée chilienne on soupçonne le
président eduardo frei montalva d'avoir
été assassiné avec un poinçon
confectionné à cologna 10
en ceci que l'enclavé salle à fabriquer
des armes et en faire du trafic c'est à
cet endroit notamment que le gaz sarin
un gaz toxique et inodore les fabriquer
pour l'état chilien en cas de conflit
militaire nous sommes désormais en 1996
et le poche et on recommence à être
coincés par tous les faits horribles
qu'il occupe un an plus tard et prend la
fuite pour se réfugier en argentine
jusqu'à ce que soit enfin
reconnu et jugées coupables de ces actes
en 2005 donc 20 ans et le jugement
prononcé envers paul schaeffer pour ces
actes abominables et seulement cinq ans
après sa condamnation par schaeffer
meure en prison à l'âge de 88 ans mais
maintenant que sont devenus les habitats
de la colonne
il y aurait un peu plus de 200
survivants aujourd'hui
un autre rescapé winfried hommes feld
âgé d'une quarantaine d'années explique
n'avoir rencontré ses parents qu'à l'âge
de 10 ans pour lui c'est comme si nous
étions nés dans une serre un laboratoire
avec absolument aucune possibilité
d'avoir conscience de nous mêmes il y
avait un dieu il s'appelait schaefer
winfried est aujourd'hui avocat il est
chargé d'une plainte collective avec
d'anciens membres de la secte la plainte
vise à la fois à l'état chilien pour
avoir laissé cet horrible endroit existé
mais elle concerne aussi l'état allemand
qui n'est pas venu en aide à ses
ressortissants
l'objectif du collectif est d'obtenir la
somme d'un million de dollars en guise
de dédommagement pour chacune des
victimes en 2019 on sait que l'allemagne
a apporté une aide financière d'environ
10000 dollars à chaque victime mais
c'était de bien au delà du montant a été
jugée insuffisante par les victimes
elles-mêmes
ce qui est dingue dans cette histoire
c'est que la population chilienne
n'était pas au courant de ce qui se
passait là bas en 1977 une enquête
réalisée par amnesty international a mis
en lumière les tortures réalisé à
colonia dignidad d'un procès a été
ouvert pour interdire la diffusion de ce
documentaire et figurez vous que ça
marche alors qu'en est il de la secte
aujourd'hui victoria donc aujourd'hui
ces lieux étaient renommés la vie y'a
pas vieira et c'est devenu un lieu
touristique avec genre épicé restera
ecce terra est dit comme ça c'est
bizarre quand on pense à tout ce qui
s'est passé et va voir sur le site urban
rider et tu lis les commentaires des
gens se disent assez et que rijkaard
savent les actes abominables qui ont eu
lieu à cet endroit qui d'un autre côté
cet endroit assez aussi beaucoup de
curieux qui veulent aller voir
bel endroit et se replonger dans les
faits qui se sont déroulés si vous avez
envie d'en savoir plus sur cette
histoire il ya un film comme il collait
bien avec emma watson et c'est vraiment
comme si vous étiez c'est super poignant
excellent film
j'espère que cette vidéo vous a
intéressé merci beaucoup à victoria
charlton d'avoir participé à cet épisode
si vous êtes passionné par les enquêtes
criminelles vous invite à faire un tour
sur sa chaîne c'est captivant vous
trouverez le lien dans la description
donc merci beaucoup famille pour cette
invitation moi je dis aux notes
si vous me connaissiez pas je m'appelle
fabien olicard et bonjour je suis
enchanté le prochain épisode des
cabinets curieux sera publiée le mois
prochain c'est tous les mois et le mois
prochain j'aurai comme invité louis san
je vous en dis pas plus pour le moment
si vous êtes très curieux vous invite à
regarder dans les liens de la
description vous avez un lien vers mon
magazine qui s'appelle furious est un
vrai magazine papier de 52 pages qui
arrive tous les mois directement dans
votre boîte aux lettres vous avez donc
un lien vers le site va vous donner
quelques articles gratuits que vous
pouvez lire et vous avez toutes les
infos là dessus ici le jour mais deux
autres vidéos mais deux anciens cabinets
curieuse ici par au dessus là vous
pouvez vous abonner
prenez soin de vous à très bientôt ciao
[Musique]
tous